BEN FRENKEL: Welcome
to this session
on developing successful
games with Google Play.
Hope you're all having a
fantastic I/O. Is that true?
You guys having a fun time here?
[CHEERS]
Whoo!
Exactly.
Let's get energized.
I know it's 10 o'clock
in the morning,
but let's get excited
for game stuff, right?
Did you guys enjoy all the
festivities last night?
Yes?
I'm seeing some nodding heads.
Did you guys like the
blankets they were handing out
because it was freezing?
I certainly did.
I grabbed one of those.
So I'm Ben Frenkel.
I'm a product manager
on the Play Games team.
And in this session,
I'm going to provide you
an overview of what Play Games
is doing for game developers.
And I'm joined today by
my esteemed colleague, TI,
who's going to go into the
nitty-gritty details of how
to implement both Play Games
and other Play services.
And we also have a very
special guest with us today,
Duke Kim from
Netmarble, who's going
to talk about both a
background for Netmarble,
what games they have,
as well as what they're
doing with Play Games
and Play overall
to improve their business.
But first, let's see
a quick show of hands.
How many of you in this
room are game developers
or involved in
the game industry?
Excellent.
That is virtually everybody.
I do see a few familiar
faces from the session
I did earlier in the week.
How many of you were
at that session?
Good amount.
All right.
Well, the good news
for you, I'm not
going to bore you with
the same material.
There is fresh content
here, and plenty of it.
But for those of you
who were not there,
I'll go and provide some
background on what Play Games
Services is all about.
So our mission is to
provide developers
the tools and services they
need to create great games,
and make money while
they're doing it, too.
And in 2013, at I/O, we
launched Play Games Services
for the first time.
And when we launched,
we had the basics.
We had achievements,
we had leaderboards,
we had a multiplayer stack,
and so on and so forth.
And since then, we've become
the fastest-growing game network
ever.
Fast forward to
today, and each month,
hundreds of millions of people
sign into Play Games Services,
and 50% of the top 500
games are integrated.
But over the years,
the needs of developers
have evolved
substantially, and we've
had to evolve along with them.
And so, Play Games
Services has since
expanded to offer things
like video recording
and predictive
analytics, and tools
to support live operations.
And another way
we've had to evolve
is, we needed to start
bringing our tools
to the different products
that our partners use.
And in particular,
what we observed
after a number of conversations
with large developers
and small developers, that
game developers typically
fell into one of two camps.
They either had their own game
engine that was built in C++,
or they used a game
engine, oftentimes a Unity
or a Cocos2d.
So just a quick show of hands,
how many of you have your own
game engine that you've
built in C++ specifically?
How many of you have something,
your own game engine,
not built in C++,
but another language?
Didn't think so.
All right.
That is not a real
thing, it turns out.
And then, how many use a
game engine of some sort?
OK, that's the vast
majority of the audience.
And that makes
sense, which is why,
when we looked at what
our partners were doing,
we realized we absolutely had to
have support for game engines.
So we actually
have a Unity plugin
that is a open-source project
that we maintain on GitHub,
and you can go check it out
and make use of those services
immediately.
In addition to that, we
also, a couple of years ago,
launched our C++ SDK, so that,
for those of you who do not
greatly enjoy crossing the JNI
bridge into Java land for doing
all of your integrations, you
can do them directly in C++
instead.
And it just so happens
that, if you have a C++ SDK,
it's relatively easy to
integrate Play Games Services
into game engines that
are built also on C++.
And Cocos2d is just
such a game engine,
and they have native support
for a number of different Play
Games Services features to
make it very easy to integrate.
And we're working with
partners to deepen and simplify
integrations all the
time, and we're always
on the lookout for
new and exciting game
engines to partner with.
One recent entry in the
game engine fray is Defold.
I don't know how many of you
are familiar with Defold,
but Defold is a
lightweight game engine
from our friends
at King, and it's
a tool that makes it very,
very easy to make games.
It's a simplified
developer experience,
so developers can focus on
the fun and engaging part
of the game.
And a few months
ago, they gave me
a sneak preview of
their integration
with Play Games Services,
and I was blown away
at how simple it was.
I had to do a double take,
because the integration looked
so easy.
And this is how
it works for them.
So you first have to go into
the Play Developer Console
and grab an ID.
This is a very easy thing to do.
And then you go into
the Defold management
console and copy and paste
it in there somewhere.
And then, once you've done
that very small bit of work,
you can then, in a
single line of code,
integrate Sign-In with
Play Games Services.
So it's almost instantaneous.
And when they
showed it to me, it
was something that I believe all
game engines should ultimately
aspire to be able to accomplish.
It should take less than
an hour to integrate,
and they really bring
that vision to fruition.
And we're excited to see
them launch their Play Games
Services support
later this year.
So there's a lot of other
territory we could cover,
but I'm going to
focus on three things
that Play Games can do to
help you engage and retain
your players.
So first, we're going to talk
about how the Play Games Video
Recording API can help
you harness the energy
and enthusiasm of
your gaming community
to deepen player engagement.
Then, we'll cover how you
can make dynamic updates
with services that Play Games
Services provides, and finally,
talk about how you can use our
predictive analytics to tune
and tailor your game to
different player segments.
So let's kick
things off with how
we can help you deepen your
engagement with your player
community.
So for a bit of
background, late last year,
we made it possible for players
to record their gameplay
from the Play Games app.
And in the next few weeks, we'll
be making the Video Recording
API available to all
developers, so that players
will be able to invoke that same
recording experience directly
from your games.
And Duke is going to talk about
how they're doing that in some
of Netmarble titles later on.
Players will also
have the option
to live stream their
gameplay to YouTube, as well.
It's a really powerful feature.
And we've seen a
lot of excitement
around video recording, from
the very smallest developers
to the largest we
have in the platform.
And more than a dozen
partners, including Netmarble,
prominently, have already
launched an integration,
because they are participating
in our early access program.
And like I said, this will
be available to everybody
in the coming weeks.
And all the games that
you're seeing up here,
you can check out on
the Play Store today,
so you can get an idea of
how the integrations work.
One such excellent
integration is from a partner
of ours, Camex Games.
And I was really impressed for
a number of different reasons,
and I'll walk you through
how their integration works.
So from one of the
battle screens here,
you can see on
your left, there's
a little recording icon.
And if you click that button,
it brings up a video recording
overlay.
And from that overlay,
you have all the controls
you need to mute
the mic, turn on
and off the
forward-facing camera,
as well as start and stop video
recording, as you would expect.
And then, once you're
done recording your video,
you can then share
it on YouTube.
And you can see on the
screen on your right,
here, that I've been able to
clip the video from the end.
And you can also observe
from the screenshot,
here, that the engine
has prefilled the title
and description
with helpful data
to speed up the process
of sharing replays.
And from Michael Tseng,
the COO of Camex Games,
they said, "the
Google standalone
Recording SDK took less
than a day to implement,
and players are recording
clips every day now."
Less than a day to implement.
So it's a very quick
and easy integration.
You can do it in a very
short period of time,
and immediately get
your players engaged
with the video
recording capabilities.
And another thing
that I very much
liked about their
integration was
that they made the feature
prominent in multiple places
in their game.
So off of the main screen, you
could launch the recording--
so ultimately, you could
share a much broader range
of experiences-- and they also
included, as I showed before,
from the battle screen.
And the more visible the
feature is, the more likely
your players are to
find it and use it.
In addition to that, they also
turned the video recording
capabilities into a selling
point for Hero Tactics.
So when you go
into the game, they
would promote the
use of the feature,
and they even featured it
in their store listings.
And all these different
things that they've
done to provide visibility to
the video recording feature
have been very successful.
So 12% of their users
have recorded videos,
and most of them have
recorded multiple videos.
And they share these
replays through all
the typical social channels,
as well as, very prominently,
YouTube.
It's a great way to engage
your audience deeply and have
them sell your game for you.
Very powerful stuff.
So now I want to talk about how
Play Games can help you make
dynamic updates to your game.
And most developers that we
talk to, very successful ones,
manage their game as a service.
And critical to that is being
able to dynamically control
different aspects of their
game from the servers.
But it's a lot of hard
work to set up and manage
these types of things,
and if you're not
a huge studio with
dedicated server engineers,
every minute you spend on this
kind of backend server work
comes at the direct expense
of working on your game.
Well, that's no
longer a requirement.
In the coming weeks, we'll be
able to use the Play Games Game
Parameters Management Tool
so that you can dynamically
manage the different parameters
that drive your game.
And with Game
Parameters Management,
you'll be able to manage
things like your virtual good
inventory, your
gameplay parameters,
manage your
different currencies,
and create time and
location-based overrides.
Now, the time and location-based
overrides are really useful.
Many developers that offer
time-limited content,
like a new character or
a level, and so forth,
still have to manually turn
on and off these promotions
and live events.
So if your promotion, let's say,
ended at 11:59:59 on a Sunday,
we've heard many
developers actually
have to have someone
come into the office
and hit a button to turn
off their promotion.
There has to be a
better way to do this.
And in fact, there is, and it
is Game Parameters Management,
just to be clear.
So if you are running
a global business
and you want promotions to be
run at locally-relevant times,
with our time and
country-based overrides,
you'll be able to specify
country-specific start and stop
times, and we automatically
manage everything for you.
And like all of
our other features,
this will be available for
free in the Developer console.
And we've been
working very closely
with our partner,
Concrete Software,
throughout the development of
Game Parameters Management.
And we were inspired to build
the Game Parameters Management
service by the opportunity
to make it easier, faster
and cheaper for Concrete to
manage their game as a service.
So in the words of
Keith Pichelman,
Game Parameters Management
will drastically
cut setup time and
issues while allowing
us to create all kinds
of new promotions
they couldn't previously.
And they're looking forward
to having Game Parameters
Management in all
their future games.
But let's turn our
attention to how developers
are using the Player Stats
API to tailor game experiences
for different player segments.
So we launched the Player
Stats API last year,
and we've continued to invest
in a number of new predictions
to make the Player Stats
API even more powerful.
We launched with some
basic stats, like sessions
percentile, spend
percentile, as well as
with some predictions, the
probability that someone
is likely to churn,
as well as spend.
And we have two new
predictions coming out
in the next few weeks.
One of them is a prediction
of how much someone
is likely to spend
in the next 28 days,
and the other is the
likelihood that someone
will become a high
spender, a 95th percentile
spender or above.
And we couldn't be more
excited to see what
creative things
you'll be able to do
with these new predictions.
But I thought I'd go through
a couple of different examples
of what people are
doing, and sort
of the enthusiasm we're seeing
from the gaming community.
And so, a developer, GameResort,
felt that the Player Stats API
was one of the most exciting
things that's recently happened
for game developers,
particularly
for small developers that
don't have the resources to do
this type of work.
And that's a common
sentiment amongst many
of the smaller and indie
developers that we talk to.
The predictive analytics
power that we have
is something that is very
difficult to do independently,
and we give that capability
for free, through a Play Games
Services integration.
And what GameResort
is planning to do
with the API is to
use spend prediction
to determine whether or not
a user will show ads-- or see
ads, I should say.
And in fact, this
other developer's
already launched
such an integration.
So developer Underwater Apps has
a really exciting integration
of the Player Stats API.
They integrated Player Stats
into their game Tapventures,
and used the spend
prediction signal
to determine if users should
see ads, as I was describing.
And if a user was predicted to
spend, they saw no ads at all,
and if a user is not
projected to spend,
they saw ads every time
they opened up the game.
And they ran an experiment that
compared their current approach
to serving ads to the
new approach, powered
by spend prediction, and the
results speak for themselves.
So revenue from ads was 17%
higher in the cohort predicted
not to spend, and
not showing ads
to users that were probable to
spend increased in-ad purchase
transactions by 15%.
You can see the quote there.
But another really exciting
example that we just recently
heard about is from
our partner eRepublik,
who's implemented another great
use case for Player Stats.
So eRepublik has an internal
custom relationship management
system they use to
track support tickets,
and so forth, and manage
outbound communication
to players.
And all the tickets
in their queue
are prioritized based
on-- at least today,
and before they have these
new predictions involved--
based on how much
people are spending.
So your big spenders, the
people who spend it all,
get prioritized
over other folks.
But with the Player
Stats, they've
added churn and
spend predictions
to their prioritization model
to help identify users that
have yet to spend
that are likely to,
and try to retain users
that are at risk of churn.
And we're excited to see
what other creative use cases
eRepublik can come up with.
This was something that we
think that many people who
have their own custom
relationship management
tools, internally, can
replicate and benefit from.
And with that, I'll
hand things over to TI.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TI CHANG: Thanks, Ben.
My name is TI Chang, and I'm
developer for Games Partners.
Google has numerous
excellent products,
but this time, I
want to specifically
focus on their
product, [INAUDIBLE]
mobile games I worked with.
As you know, there
is a huge competition
in those segments
of the game market,
and the developers are very
cautious about when they
decide the product they use.
The product,
[INAUDIBLE], for them,
can be regarded as
competitive in the market.
Moreover, I'd like to show
you how easy to use them.
Here are five product
really, really worked well
for my partners.
Let me go through them one
by one, and what they are,
and how to use.
The first one is
Pre-registration.
Pre-registration has been
a very common practice
in PC gaming world.
When you launch a
game, then you usually
do the beta testing, and
pre-registration, and launch.
Google provides seamless
onboarding experience
through Google Play
Pre-registration.
It's one of the most effective
user acquisition tool,
and helps the
developer from day one.
In APAC, especially
Japan and Korea,
this is the most common
practice in mobile.
Let me go through the
actual user experience
for Pre-registration.
When a big title, like
Clash Royale, is launching,
we prepare a free
registration event before,
and share the message through
various marketing channels,
so the user can
discover and sign up.
When user clicks the
banner or follows the link,
then they go to the game page in
Play Games store-- Play Store,
sorry-- sign up for
the pre-registration.
At the day of game
launch, the user
gets a notification
to install the game
so that they won't miss it.
We found that this type
of onboarding experience
helps to [? rustle ?]
partners by helping
hundreds of thousands of users
to install their game from day
one.
Many of the pre-registered
users remain
to be highly engaging and loyal
to the games for a long time.
Previously, signing in Google
Play Games was depending
on the users Google+ profile,
which sometimes introduced
frictions.
If you don't have a Google+
profile in your account,
then you have to create it, and
also give a consent each game
before you start.
With the recent
update of Play Games,
now you can sign in without
using Google+ anymore.
Instead, we introduce a
new gamer ID and avatar,
which are not connected to
any of the personal data
in Google's properties,
and also can be used
to identify you among games.
So you don't need
to give the consent
to every game you install.
If you create a gamer ID for
the first game you sign in,
then all other games
you install later
will automatically use it, and
won't interrupt you any more.
Here is the previous sample
called Play Games sign-in.
You can notice that it used
to use Plus.API and Scope.
Now, you won't use it.
Just use Games.API, and
Scope will work fine.
If your game is still
using Google+ features,
such as profiles or
[INAUDIBLE] code,
then you still need to add
Google+ functionalities.
Then, please use
setRequireGooglePlus method
to notify to Play Games.
This will help you handle
the rest of the process.
The next great
feature in Play Games,
obviously, is Video
Recording API.
Ben already gave you how
it works on overview,
but I want to focus on how
easy the integration is.
Video Recording feature
is in Play Games App,
and you can use it by simply
invoking the recording
widget from your game.
Just two lines of
coding make this work.
But please bear in mind
that the feature required
to install the latest version
of the Play Games app,
and devices with Android 5.0
or above, so you'd better
notify this to your users,
before you let them use it.
Also, the recording quality
of the video recording
is depending on the performance
of the device and your game.
Here, you can see how the
video recording works.
This is a kind of video
recorded by the [INAUDIBLE].
And it shows you how you
can invoke the recording
widget from the game, and
click to record the gameplay.
Can you play the video record?
Thank you.
You can see my face and the
screen recorded together.
Once you're done, just
click the Stop button,
and choose to upload
it to YouTube.
Play it again.
Hey, it's cool.
BEN FRENKEL: We
can see it twice.
TI CHANG: Yeah.
BEN FRENKEL: So if you
could stop the video.
TI CHANG: Can you
stop the video?
OK.
So integration takes
just two lines of coding.
Start the activity
for recording video
with an OverlayRecordingIntent.
This API will be
public soon after I/O.
Player Stats API is a
great tool to get insight
from the user stats.
If you know a user about
the segment he belongs to,
you can tailor the game
experience to make it better
for the specific user.
The API will tell you lots of
things about the user, based
on the data regarding player
progression, spending,
and engagement.
Player Stats API
also predicts how
the user will behave
in the future,
based on Google's powerful
machine learning technologies.
It will tell you the
user will churn or spend,
or whether he will
be a high spender,
or how much he will spend
within the next 28 days.
Let us see how a user
can tailor the game
experience with this API.
If the user is likely to
spend, you can turn off all ads
to make the experience better.
Or he's unlikely
to spend, then you
can show ads every 20 minutes.
If the user is
about to churn, you
can suggest a chance
to try a powerful item
to make him stay longer.
If the user has not come
back for just 10 days,
you can send him a
notification about how
his friends are doing.
He might come back to check it.
If the user is likely
to be a big spender,
you can show him
a special VIP Item
which is more expensive
and more powerful.
Using Player Stats
API is so simple.
You can call
loadPlayerStats method
and get the data in the
result [? callback. ?]
The prediction
starts working soon,
within just a couple of
days after first sign-in.
The more he plays and leaves the
trace in Play Games, the better
prediction you will get.
So please try to use as many
features of Play Games as
possible.
It will help you get more
accurate data and predictions.
And last not but the
least, In-App Promotion
is another powerful tool you
can use from Google Play.
With the In-App Promotion,
you can reward your loyal user
and the newcomers.
Think about a game
community event in which you
can introduce your new game
and share some promo codes
to the attendees with
a special in-app item.
As long as your game is using
In-App Billing Version 3,
the integration
costs very little.
Let me show you how
the process works.
First, you can go to
the developer console
and generate promo
code connected
to a specific in-app item.
Then, distribute the codes to
the users' marketing channels,
such as social network,
or blogs, or Messenger.
Once users get the code, they
can redeem it within game
or within Play Store.
Your game client can
handle this redemption
as part of In-App
Billing Version 3.
Finally, the user
gets the reward,
and you can successfully
cultivate the loyal users.
This is a screen of
Play Developer Console.
You can create a promotion.
You can define a promotion
with the start and end dates.
You can link it
to an in-app item,
and also specify the number
of codes you generate.
Let me tell you how to
handle this within your game.
When the code is redeemed
during the user in-app purchase
process inside the
game, by choosing
redeem option of the payment
UI, this is almost identical to
with normal In-App
Billing Version 3,
except that there is no
orderId in the purchase data,
since there are no
actual transactions.
When the code is redeemed in
Play Store, outside of game,
the thing will be a
little bit different.
You can redeem the
code before installing,
or while running the app.
In that case, you
can handle redemption
when the game starts.
When the code is
redeemed in Play Store
while your game
is up and running,
the store will
let your game know
that there is an update by
sending an intent called
PurchasesUpdate.
So your game should listen
to this intent and handle it.
Please note that there will be
no orderId or developer payload
when redeemed in Play Store.
Let's quickly look at the
code snippets of the last case
I just mentioned.
You should register a broadcast
receiver for the intent
when your activities
are resumed,
and unregister it
when it's paused.
On the same method
of the receiver,
you can handle the
purchased item as user,
but you will see neither a
orderId nor developer payload,
since it was not real,
actual transaction,
and purchase didn't
happen within game.
In many cases, I recommend to
create a separate in-app item
which is not visible inside the
game just for promo code only.
It's way easier to sort out
the purchase-by-redemption
from those by actual payment.
So far, I have explained
Google Play products
which was really useful
to our game partner.
Now, I want to invite
and introduce to you
Duke from Netmarble, one of
our top game partners in Korea.
Duke has been working
closely with Google
for last couple of
years, and he will
share the developer experience
from his point of view.
Duke, please come on.
[APPLAUSE]
DUKE KIM: Hello.
My name is Duke Kim.
And yeah, I have
English name, but it
doesn't mean that I can
speak English very well.
So just focusing on
the script and slide.
I just want to introduce myself.
I was a developer for 10 years,
and now I'm VP of marketing.
So I can explain the
developer's viewpoint,
and also at the same time,
a marketing point, too.
Before starting, I
just want to introduce
Netmarble, because Netmarble
is not popular here.
And Netmarble is
not young company.
It's almost 16
years old company,
and we just started
a game business
as a PC online game publisher.
And now, we are number one
mobile game publisher in Korea,
and our market share
in Korea is over 30%.
It's amazing.
And currently, we make
money in Korea, maybe 48%,
and then the rest coming
from outside of Korea.
And we are number eight
worldwide mobile revenue
in last year.
I introduced MARVEL
Future Fight.
We used [INAUDIBLE] for
promoting this title,
and this title
launched in April 2015,
last year, in the
top 10 grossing
in a major Asian country,
including Taiwan, Thailand,
Korea-- yeah, not
good result in Japan--
and the top 20 grossing in US.
I prepared a video to spend
time. [CHUCKLES] Wait a minute.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Relinquish all hope.
There is no use in resisting.
There is only pain.
I, [INAUDIBLE], am your
new lord and master.
[END PLAYBACK]
DUKE KIM: Next time I
will prepare more longer
version. [LAUGHS] Yeah,
MARVEL Future Fight has
had Google promotion
event for a week
at the launching
time of last year.
And during this event,
the user received a reward
when they entered get
the game after clicking
the Google promote banner
at the Google Play top page.
A total of 40,000 users
participate in that event
and used the promo code.
From this, our new registered
users were increased by 15%.
This number comparison
during the event week
and the previous
week of the event.
At that time, our
goal was understanding
how to use Google promo code.
Because in Korea,
in Asia, coupon
is a very popular marketing
method at offline,
and that is very important.
And we want to expand that
experience outside of Korea,
outside of Asia, but there
is no way to spread a coupon.
But because of a
Google promo code,
I think we can find the right
method to use our knowledge
about the coupon in Asia.
And I want to introduce
the next game.
The next game is Raven.
Raven is a console-quality hack
and slash RPG, [INAUDIBLE].
Raven.
Raven was launched in
March of last year,
and maintained
number one grossing
is Google Play Korea for
more than six months.
It's record.
This game has broken
several market records
in download and sales,
and largely drove
Netmarble's revenue
in last year.
During the last year,
Korea Game Awards Ceremony,
Raven won the highest
honor, grand [? prize, ?]
and also a Top Developer prize.
And is also scored award for
scenario, sound, graphics,
and domestic popularity.
Here, the gameplay
clip of Raven.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
DUKE KIM: OK, next slide.
Raven has had a
Google promotion event
for a week from 24 September
to 1 October of last year,
during the Korean
Thanksgiving holidays.
The event process was very
similar to MARVEL Future Fight,
and the user would receive a
reward when enter in the game
after clicking the promo banner
at the top page of Google Play.
You can see the effect.
DAU increasing.
New registration increasing.
Returning user increasing.
Revenue increasing.
But the most important
thing is, with this event,
we improved our retention rate.
Because every day, user
can get a different reward
from Google Play, so you
just continuously log in,
log in, log in, for a week.
That is the most powerful
effect of a Google promo code.
And EvilBane is the
global version of Raven.
It's a blockbuster-quality
action RPG launched this year.
In Taiwan, we are number two.
Thailand, we're number four.
Hong Kong is number seven.
We did many things
for Western market.
Left side is original
version, and the right side
is the new version.
We changed the UI, and
we developed new pictures
to meet the taste of Western.
But we still try to
understand the Western gamers,
because there are huge
difference between Asian gamers
and Western gamers.
Asian gamers usually spend
four or five hours a day
to play games.
Crazy, right?
But Western, it's just spend
maybe a half hour a day.
A huge difference.
So the same balance will
not work outside of Korea,
outside of Asia.
So they get headache
over Netmarble.
And we did pre-registration.
Pre-registration is
really important in Asia,
because every Asia gamer want to
be a number one among players.
That means the easiest way is,
start game earlier than others.
So pre-registration is the
best way to start game earlier.
So that means, for
Netmarble, that
is best way to collect loyal
user before launching the game.
So our pre-registration result
is really, really important
for us.
And in Korea, in Asia, we
can collect phone number
without any limitation.
But outside Korea,
that is not normal.
And we tried
collecting email, we
tried collecting [INAUDIBLE]
ID, and every time, we failed.
But with a Google team, the
new future of pre-registration,
finally, we find
out the best way
to do pre-registering
campaign outside of Korea.
Here, the chart is
really hard to explain,
because of my English problem.
Anyway, we accomplished a DAU
of 200,000 on the first day
of the launching, with the
help of pre-registration
and the Google
[? pre-training. ?] And
the Google [? pre-training ?]
very powerful, but problem is,
it is really hard to
collecting core users.
But with the
pre-registration, we
believe we succeeded to collect
loyal user or hard-core gamer
outside of Korea.
And we also adopt a
video recording feature.
Hopefully, with this
feature, we can make a sort
of a user community at YouTube.
And we try, now, and we
digging the possibility
of this picture.
But currently, it has
just fundamental feature.
Just user can recording
and uploading,
and we need more feature to
meet the IP holder's needs,
like Disney and
Marvel and Warner.
And we're discussing about
that with Google continuously,
and I think, at
the launching time,
you can use this feature
more powerfully than us.
And finally, I just want
to cover Player Stats API.
You can predict spender,
and you can predict churn.
It looks like cool.
And Netmarble, Netmarble
is big company,
so we have our own
prediction model.
We have our own churn
But problem is, at
the launching time,
we don't have enough
data to-- how can
I say-- to use our own model.
But Player Stats API looks
like give me meaningful result
at the launching time.
So I think, after launching
one or two months,
we can use our model.
But at the starting time,
the Player Stats API
is very important to
predict what will happen.
And we were thinking
about using that
for promoting some
of our in-app item,
and also using that to
predict the marketing budget.
Yeah.
OK, thank you.
And I just give it to Ben.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]